[Music]
well can I help you
that is to say Ken as a matter of fact
you can that's so considerate of you to
ask you see I was over by the bar back
there and I said now there's a young man
who could be a great assistance
accompanying me back to my hotel
Alice much is that it's flattering at it
no no I'm simply not a homosexual man
and so the dance begins a two-step where
each of us cloaks our true desires for
fear of rejection like a mystery ball
the path to unmasking one's truth is
rife with self deceit
there's only one problem I haven't a
mask
and I'm too old to dance oh come now you
and I both know this act is pointless a
young man like you could learn a thing
or two from me having a man like me show
you the ropes why don't we just skip
this whole charade stop wasting
everyone's time as you accompany me to
my god that seems it's a very least
mildly inappropriate for lunchtime I've
always loved a barricade of age
unfortunately it's one of this world's
greatest ironies that those guarding the
most valuable treasures don't understand
their true worth now now Ben I of course
misspoke when I called you a boy
obviously you're a young man I think
it's one of this country's greatest and
justices the strapping young lad like
you just a few mirror years shy of a
driver's license can't so much as enjoy
a simple beer with his friend so some of
this earth small fleshly pleasures wait
you think I'm a boy no of course not
you're a young man no no I I mean I'm 35
take another clip from the full show
Daily Show at ladder with credit comm
slash mug club or it's available
exclusively $69 a year that's less than
$6 a month less than two expensive cups
of coffee or you can feed an African
child but just buy coffee or join the
mug club Daily Show ladder with
credit.com slash mug club see you there
don't feed children